about a week ago i
put together a what you call my call an
extended montage of vu clips vu was a
interesting social media
platform in which people would record
um
up to two minute
clips of of them usually from their
webcams i think some people get a little
bit more sophisticated
and you would respond to questions or
comments from from other v users
and uh eventually it it got to be quite
large there were a lot of people doing
it but it ended up folding so they sent
all of us vusers all of our footage if
we asked for it
and i've been wading through the stuff
and organizing it so this is another one
of those
10 vu clips these are all focused on on
ethics and you might say on the sort of
big picture general issue type of stuff
i'm going to be shooting i've got enough
footage for a number of other ones on
ethics and i'll be shooting those
or rather editing those together with a
little intro clip like this
over the next couple weeks so if you if
you enjoy this sort of thing
here you go
okay so another question from one of my
ethics class students and this is one
that comes up every single semester in
every class sometimes throughout the
entire semester because it's a really
big worry that people have particularly
in our culture where it seems like moral
norms are are clearly not not shared
across the board and yet we we all use
moral vocabulary so it seems like you
can't get away from you know moral
judgments together
but who gets to decide right so my
question is who is the one to determine
what is truly right or wrong
and i'd like to point out just just a
couple things with that first thing is
the really simple answer that is uh you
are
by virtue of being a human being
you make moral judgments
you can't avoid making moral judgments
and it's really interesting because if
you look at moral theories all across
the board
almost all of them
agree on at least this thing you have to
judge something as being right and
something is being wrong or good or bad
aristotle actually says that this is
part of our our human nature that we
it's even part of our language it's how
we're different from the animals that we
we recognize
good bad right wrong just unjust and the
other animals don't they only recognize
painful pleasurable
and useful or harmful
the other thing that i'd like to point
out is if you notice how this question
is phrased
who is the one to determine what is
truly right or wrong and that that truly
right there that's very important
because what it indicates
is that
one could be mistaken about this
right so
in in making a moral judgment one is not
necessarily saying i know i'm completely
correct about this i couldn't possibly
be wrong nobody could convince me that
there's some there's some better way of
looking at things
but you shouldn't be afraid to make
moral judgments
there you go
so this is actually a follow-up question
um how can moral philosophy be
objectively applicable or satisfying
um language is a little bit confused
there i'm not quite sure if i know
exactly what the person has in mind but
i'm guessing by objectively applicable
what they mean is that i can trust it
that
other people can trust it that
it could actually
apply across the board
you know that's one of those sort of
questions that we address early on in
classes about moral philosophy
if you don't think that there are any
moral norms that we can reason out
that apply to people
in general or across the board well you
can't do moral philosophy
um
not going to find a lot of philosophers
who actually hold that that view
you won't actually find a lot of
criminals who hold that view i can tell
you having worked in a maximum security
prison taught there for for years and
years
um
moral philosophy
when we say that it's
objective we don't mean that everybody
agrees
or that everybody recognizes that's an
interesting feature of
of moral discourse and moral theory
since it applies to
right and wrong and applies to you know
human beings who are caught in these
webs of vulnerability and have to
develop and quite often have mistaken
viewpoints you're not going to get
everybody to agree and so if that's what
you mean by objective
you need to find another field like say
physics right because because moral
norms are not of that sort satisfying i
find the study of moral systems
inherently satisfying but that's because
i enjoy the life of the mind
i think a lot of it is a matter of
practice sort of like the athlete enjoys
physical activity
and gamesmanship because they they've
done it and they're good at it same
thing if you work in the life of the
mind the longer you do it the more you
enjoy it if you're actually working with
the right things
so i'm finally catching up on on my vu
questions and this is a really
interesting one
for a couple reasons is the notion of
being right or wrong just a delusion
that we create in our own minds
uh followed up i do such things hinder
or warp the human psyche
so
let me say yes and no
um
being right or wrong in the sense of you
know like being completely right being
completely wrong
or actions being right or wrong or being
right or wrong about
particular beliefs or in holding certain
values
is the notion of being right or wrong
just a delusion that we created our own
minds no
um
as a matter of fact it's a basic
uh experience of of
human life and and moral life is
is uh inextricably connected with that
even you know to say that these things
hinder or warp the human psyche you're
making value judgments you're making
judgments about what's good and bad
right and wrong
well our understanding of what's right
or wrong
and the degree of adequacy to which we
understand those things you know whether
we understand them in very simplistic
ways or whether we understand them in
more
complex ways because reality is quite
complex
those
could hinder or warp the human psyche if
you i mean aristotle and plato talk
about this and sort of
epictetus and a lot of ancient
philosophers
if you have mistaken views about human
nature or about what the good is or how
to order different goods in your life or
how you want to be treating people and
you can be getting these through
observation and then not you know
thinking things through carefully or
your your own emotions your passions
could steer you in the wrong direction
you could be getting these from your
culture or society
um
there's a lot of different places that
these these could come from
these can hinder or warp the human
psyche in it both in its development you
know and how it comes about
and how it uh gets
better or gets worse over time and also
in the moment-to-moment times when we we
have to make
decisions
decisions that affect our character
decisions that affect who we're going to
become
also affecting our relationships
which is a large part of who we are
so you know for instance if you have the
view that other people are merely there
to be exploited for your your own ends
and that they don't have any value in
themselves except in so far as they
contribute to your own
desires being satisfied or your own
well-being
and you act on that what you will do if
you have that view you're going to
hinder your development you're going to
set it back you're going to warp
your psyche and eventually you will have
a very difficult time even if you wanted
to change that
no longer seeing things that way
should we be teaching ethics in k-12 and
should it be mandatory in higher ed yes
to both
and let's make a distinction here
between uh teaching ethics in the sense
of endorsing a particular ethical
approach or ethical theory
and um teaching about
ethical theories or ethical approaches
and you know doing it comparatively and
and you know working out which one might
be better or more applicable in a
particular situation for students
both of those ought to be done k through
12 both of those ought to be done in
higher ed they're not
and
part of it is i think because we have
this this discomfort in our society
about teaching about right and wrong and
people
how do they get good at that well you
actually have to have arguments about it
and you have to have discussions and you
can't just sort of pull back and say oh
no no we can't talk about that that's
the realm of morality
um you get better at it by like anything
else by practice by engaging by thinking
about it
i think we ought to be doing that i
think that um we philosophy professors
who are are you know not the only people
who can teach ethics but we're the ones
who actually have a special focus on it
we ought to be teaching the k through 12
teachers how to how to do it well
i think that in in better schools
uh should it be mandatory for herod
better schools it is
and you don't just do it with one course
actually in better schools you have a
real emphasis on it because it's not
something that you can just teach and
then and then you're done with and
forget about it's got to be infused
through the curriculum
and again i think philosophers ought to
be taking the lead on that although i
don't see them doing it
i did actually hear
at fsu by helping to form the ethics and
business education
project and the whole goal was to not
not go into business classes and teach
business ethics but for us philosophers
to help the business professionals the
business educators raise their levels of
competence and and confidence in
teaching students so they could see that
this is something worth taking seriously
and i think that's important
yes i think ethics should be taught in
school because one way or the other
you're going to do it so you may as well
do it thoughtfully and do it coherently
and do it well
i like the way in which you framed this
question
because this could actually be like a
whole this is something i would spend a
whole class period on if i if i was in
an ethics class just
unpacking all the different assumptions
and sort of permutations on it because
we operate on a personal level in
regards to moral value judgments do you
feel ethics should be taught in school
and i would say yes precisely because we
operate on a personal level in regards
to moral value judgments for a couple
different reasons
one is
we grow as ethical beings that is we
make moral progress we develop
and this is part of the the human
is part of the nature of human beings
and society
we do that in part through moving from
lower stages to higher and higher stages
of ethical development of having better
moral theories now they don't have to be
you know like explicitly framed as
theories
but they can be embodied in in the way
in which you live
and because we operate on on personal
levels that means that different people
are going to be at different levels so
some people are at a very low level
and just respond to you know reward
punishment they're only they're purely
selfish they don't take account of
how their behaviors affect others
and then you know once you start to take
account of that you can start thinking
of different reasons why you care about
how it affects others do you care
because it's a matter of principle do
you care because you're getting
something out of it you care just
because you want warm fuzzies from
people thinking you're a nice person
those are all different um
those are different
moral positions and they represent
different moral theories so yeah this is
a great question actually
okay so this is a follow-up to my
response to the question about whether
ethics should be taught in k-12 and in
college where i said yes it should
uh okay so if you teach ethics in school
isn't that pushing your morality on
students
real issue there yeah
i am i'm definitely
attuned to that issue
and you have to be careful to put things
in place to make sure that it isn't just
going to be
simply imposing one conception of right
and wrong
onto students which actually is not even
very productive from from the standpoint
of teaching ethics and moral development
which requires that there actually be
some discussion and debate and even
conflict and sometimes even making
mistakes
in order for there to be progress
i think there is a real danger of of
once you start deliberately talking
about ethics in school about pushing one
thing or another i think there's also
it's quite clear that if you don't do
ethics in school you are still doing
ethics you're just doing a very bad one
you're doing one that's kind of careless
haphazard thrown together and the
students are getting ideas about right
and wrong from somewhere whether you
want them to or not
so again i would make a distinction
between teaching a particular scheme of
ethics which you know
at a basic level yeah we do have to do
that tell the students don't hit each
other that's that's that's an ethical
doctrine right
um but also teaching them about various
uh standpoints and theories and their
their
weaknesses their strengths how they can
speak to each other
i think that's really important because
with without that
the students don't
they don't think about it they don't
engage
and part of what we're looking for is
not people who have the right wrong
answer for every single thing but people
who have a good idea about how to
proceed
to generate
at least something like a right answer
when they're posed with difficult
situations i think we can do that in
school
okay so this is a
deep entangled set of questions here
that i'm not going to be able to fully
address within two minutes so i i
finally have brought home to me
the fact that i need to do what some
other view users have done and start
recording
uh discussions and answers to some of
these questions on on my youtube channel
and i'm going to do that with with this
one about objectivity
and
teaching ethics and pushing morality
so let me just give a few
broad outlines
and a few
partial answers
isn't philosophy objective and logical
um
yes and no
to begin with when we use that term
logical that's not something that all
philosophers actually agree on if we
look at the history of philosophy
there's formal logic and you know that's
really basic stuff but that gets you
nowhere
there's nothing substantive to that as
soon as we start getting into
substantive logics
then things start getting a lot more
controversial and the subject starts
becoming involved and it's no longer
just as
objective now some people reject that
that whole notion of anything beyond a
formal logic being a logic but
again you know other philosophers
haven't
isn't philosophy objective it aims at
objectivity but objectivity is not by
itself the the you know most important
thing in the world there's actually
whole schools of philosophy that stress
the importance of subjectivity
uh what paul records called good
subjectivity existentialism for example
begins from our subjective standpoint
and says that that that's very important
i don't think a prof can push his or her
morality onto students otherwise they're
not teaching
um you've got a couple different things
mixed up there
professors do push their morality on
students and sometimes they they are
teaching sometimes that can be an
integral part so i'm going to leave it
off there
so i take it you sending me to tony's
flood site wasn't actually because you
actually um
are interested in tony flood but because
you want me to react to clifford's uh
ethics of belief
is his famous essay which happens to be
housed there but happens to be housed at
like a thousand other sites so at first
i was going on flood site which i i
thank you for showing me i've heard the
guy's name um
and something tells me that i've
actually run across him at a conference
but i've never actually looked at his
site turns out that he and i share quite
a few um
interests and uh heroes in in common
including norris clark
a great perk thomas personalist
philosopher
eric vigeland um
ernst casir and lord acton he's also
it seems to be quite infatuated with
some processed theologians who i
have no interest in whatsoever
and um
with lonergan who i have a hard time
taking very seriously
um
but that be that as me okay so you're
asking me about clifford's ethics of
belief i think clifford's wrong i think
that he is
wrong in an interesting way he's wrong
on on some points he's wrong in the
emphasis and i i buy william james's
critique of
of um
uh clifford that we would not only never
get anything done if we held rigorously
to his beliefs
to his views on things but that he
cannot even take account of his own
ethics of belief according to his ethics
belief which is a problem of consistency
but even more that
if you don't actually extend yourself
and make the experiment and try things
out you will never actually
have any grounds for believing many
things that you actually would
later on have good grounds for believing
if you
extended yourself and risked
and um
okay so interesting i i should actually
do a longer thing about this but i'll do
that
i think that i might do some writing uh
maybe on virtue ethics digest
about this or or maybe in one of my dr
sadler chalk and talks talking about
this because this is a really important
question
when do we have the opportunity to
practice
virtue ethics in our daily lives so
let's think about what it means to to
practice this sort of thing
we become virtuous by doing
actions that are in accordance with
virtue we don't yet have virtue at that
point
but we're acting the way that a virtuous
person does and we're approaching things
as best we can in the way that a
virtuous person does we're using them as
the model
and we're trying to measure up to them
you might say
so
i think in our ordinary daily lives as
plain persons to use
mcintyre's phrase
i would say the greatest opportunities
that we have are moments of one
temptation
and then two annoyance
and maybe this is going too much from my
own personal experience but
if you think about what the virtues are
they are their habits that reflect
patterns of choice that eventually
become part of our personality part of
our character so our vices
uh and virtues
sort of incline us to to
make the right decisions to go the right
ways to choose the right action at the
right time to feel the way that we ought
to
towards the things that we ought to
so when does this come up the most often
when is it needed the most often when
we're tempted by something that we know
at least on some level we probably
shouldn't pursue but we feel that desire
we feel a temptation for it
and i would say annoyance too because
some of the virtues are actually
concerned with things like patience you
know control of over anger
you know keeping our impulses under
control and i think that those are
situations like that so and more a lot
more to say about this